오늘은 회전하는 공에 대해 알려드릴 건데요, 사실 공도 아니고 회전도 아니에요. Qiskit 교실에서
스핀이라는 양자 특성에 대해 이야기할 거예요. 처음으로 그 증거를 발견한 실험을 살펴보면서요.
Qiskit 교실에 오신 걸 환영해요. 이 시리즈에서는 Qiskit을 사용해 양자 컴퓨팅 관련 강의에서
흔히 다루는 몇 가지 기본 개념들을 탐구해 볼 거예요. 각 영상에는 인터랙티브 모듈도 함께 제공되는데
설명란에 링크가 있으니 꼭 확인해 보세요. 오늘은 1922년 슈테른-게를라흐 실험에 대해 이야기할 거예요.
이 실험은 양자 이론 역사에서 가장 유명한 실험 중 하나예요. 왜냐하면 양자
스핀이 어떻게 작동하는지 너무나 명확하게 보여주거든요. 하지만 그건 슈테른이나 게를라흐가 원래 보여주려 했던 게 아니었어요. 이 실험은 새로운 양자 원자 모델을 검증하기 위해 설계됐어요.
보어 모델이라고 하는 이 모델은 1913년에 제안한 닐스 보어의 이름을 딴 거예요. 이 모델에서 전자는 불연속적인 궤도를 돌고
광자를 흡수하거나 방출함으로써 그 궤도 사이를 전환할 수 있어요.
각 궤도는 양자화된 각운동량을 가지고 있었는데, 그건 아주 작은 기본 상수의 정수 배였어요.
h라고 부르는 이 상수는요. 1910년대와 20년대 초에는 양자역학이 완전히 새로운 분야였어요. 너무 새로워서
아직 양자역학이라는 이름조차 없었을 정도예요. 그래서 보어 모델을 확신하는 사람이 다들 있었던 건 아니었어요. 물리학자
Otto Stern은 그것을 정말 싫어했어요. 그 모델을 말도 안 된다고 했고, 보어가 옳다고 증명되면 물리학을 그만두겠다는 말까지 했어요.
슈테른은 그 모델이 틀렸다는 걸 증명하려는 의지가 너무 강해서 기발한 검증 방법을 생각해냈어요. 그리고
Walther Gerlach를 불러 실험을 설계하고 진행하는 데 도움을 받았어요. 결과적으로 그는 보어가 틀렸다는 걸 증명하지 못했어요.
오히려 자기 자신이 틀렸다는 걸 증명하게 됐죠. 실험이 너무 단순하고 결과가 너무 명확해서 그 논쟁은 사실상 마무리됐어요.
원자 규모에서는 양자역학이 지배한다는 거요. 당시에는 깨닫지 못했지만
슈테른-게를라흐 실험은 전자의 내재적 스핀에 대한 결정적인 증거도 발견했어요. 이건
자성, 초전도성, 그리고 현대 화학의 많은 부분을 설명하는 데 필수적인
자연의 새로운 기본 특성이에요. 오늘은 슈테른-게를라흐 실험이 어떻게 작동하는지, 실험에서 고전적으로 기대할 수 있는 것이 무엇인지,
그리고 슈테른과 게를라흐가 실제로 발견한 게 무엇인지 살펴볼 거예요. 그런 다음 Qiskit과 IBM 양자 컴퓨터로
여러분 자신만의 슈테른-게를라흐 실험을 어떻게 실행할 수 있는지 보여드릴게요. 슈테른-게를라흐 실험의 기본 아이디어는
원자 내 전자의 각운동량이 양자화되어 있는지 알아낼 방법을 찾는 거였어요. 보어가 예측한 대로인지,
아니면 슈테른이 예상한 대로 그렇지 않은지 검증하려 했죠. 전자의 각운동량이 각 원자 주변에 작은 자기장을 만들기도 한다는 사실을 활용했어요.
그래서 원자들을 아주 작은 막대자석처럼 생각할 수 있어요.
실험은 이렇게 생겼어요. 은 원자가 가득 찬 오븐이 있고
북극과 남극이 있는 자기장이 있어요.
위쪽 자기장이 더 강하고 아래쪽이 더 약해서 위쪽을 향한 기울기가 생겨요.
그리고 마지막으로 스크린이 있어요. 실험에서 오븐은 은 원자를 가열해서 증발시키고
각 원자의 작은 막대자석이 완전히 무작위 방향으로 정렬된 채로 오븐 밖으로 날아가게 해요. 그러면 원자들이
자기장을 통과하고, 원자들은 이 자기장 기울기에 대한 각 원자 북극의 방향에 따라 위아래로 힘을 받아요.
그런 다음 원자들이 스크린에 부딪혀요. 슈테른과 게를라흐는 원자들이 스크린의 어디에 부딪히는지 봐서 전자의 각운동량에 대해 알아낼 수 있었어요.
슈테른은 실험의 원자들이 지금까지 설명한 대로, 즉 고전 물리학의 규칙을 따르는 작은 막대자석처럼 행동할 거라고 예상했어요.
고전적으로 이 작은 원자 자석들은 임의의 어떤 방향으로든 정렬될 수 있어요.
그래서 자기장을 통과할 때 그 방향에 따라 다양한 크기의 힘을 위아래로 받을 수 있어요. 자기장 기울기와
같은 방향을 가리키는 자석은 위로 큰 힘을 받고, 반대 방향이면
아래로 큰 힘을 받아요. 그 중간 어딘가면 약한 힘이 작용하죠. 원자가 기울기에 수직으로 가리키면
힘을 받지 않고 그냥 직진하게 돼요. 이런 다양한 힘 때문에
원자들은 스크린의 각기 다른 세로 위치에 부딪혀야 해요. 스크린에 만들어지는 패턴은
이런 모양이 될 거예요. 하지만 슈테른과
게를라흐가 본 건 그게 아니었어요. 대신 스크린에서 완전히 분리된 두 개의 원자 덩어리를 봤는데
가운데는 원자가 전혀 없었어요.
당시에는 이걸 설명할 올바른 이론이 없었지만, 지금은 그 이유를 알아요. 모든 전자가
스핀 형태의 내재적 각운동량을 가지고 있는데, 이 값은 두 가지 중 하나만 취할 수 있어요.
막대자석 그림에서 이건 원자 자석이 허용된 두 가지 방향만 가질 수 있다는 뜻이에요. 이
두 가지 방향을 스핀 업(spin up)과 스핀 다운(spin down)이라고 불러요. 양자 컴퓨터의 qubit은
이런 스핀 시스템과 닮았어요. 일부 양자 컴퓨터는 실제로 전자 스핀 상태로 만든 qubit을 사용해요.
그래서 Qiskit과 IBM 양자 컴퓨터의 qubit으로 우리만의 슈테른-게를라흐 실험을 수행할 수 있어요.
전자의 스핀 업 상태를 qubit의 0 상태에 대응시키고, 스핀 다운 상태를 qubit의 1 상태에
대응시킬 거예요. 은 입자들이 오븐에서 나올 때 자기 모멘트가 무작위로 정렬되어 있었어요.
슈테른-게를라흐 실험을 모델링하기 위해 0 상태에서 시작하는 단일 qubit으로 간단한 quantum circuit을 만들 수 있어요.
이걸 circuit 다이어그램이라고 하는데, 맨 위 선이 qubit이고 qubit에 적용되는 연산이
선 위의 박스로 표시돼요. RX와 RZ 박스는 quantum gate로
원자의 자기 방향을 효과적으로 회전시켜요. 여기서 무작위 Theta와 F 값을 선택해서
qubit을 무작위 양만큼 회전시킬 수 있어요. 이건 무작위 스핀 방향으로 원자를 뿜어내는 오븐을 흉내 내는 거예요. 회색 박스는
측정 장치예요. qubit이 0 상태인지 1 상태인지 알려주고, 그 측정값을 고전 비트인
이중선 C로 전송해요. 이 부분은 원자가 스크린의 어느 지점에 부딪히는지 봐서 스핀 업인지 스핀 다운인지 측정하는 것과 같아요.
Qiskit의 기본 프리미티브인 sampler를 사용해서 각기 다른 무작위 Theta와 f 값으로 실험을 여러 번 실행할 수 있어요.
100번 샘플링하면 이런 모양의 측정 히스토그램을 얻어요. 약
50% 확률로 qubit이 0으로 측정되고 50% 확률로 1 상태가 나와요. 이건 슈테른과
게를라흐가 본 것과 똑같은 결과예요. 항상 스핀 업이나 스핀 다운 중 하나이고 그 중간은 절대 없어요. 이 시점에서 이렇게 생각할 수도 있어요.
물론 두 개의 불연속적인 결과가 나오죠. 이진 결과만 반환하는 디지털 양자 컴퓨터에서 실험을 수행했으니까요.
맞는 말이에요. 하지만 양자 컴퓨터가 이진 결과를 반환하는 이유, 즉 양자 컴퓨팅이 작동하는 이유가
바로 슈테른과 게를라흐가 처음 발견한 이 스핀 양자화 때문이라는 점을 기억해야 해요.
IBM 양자 컴퓨터의 qubit은 스핀을 기반으로 하지 않지만, 다른 많은 양자 컴퓨터는 그래요. 그래서
양자 컴퓨터로 슈테른-게를라흐 실험을 수행하면 스핀 양자화를 실제로 재발견할 수 있어요.
1922년 이후로 원래 슈테른-게를라흐 실험에 대한 수많은 확장 실험들이 수행됐어요. 이 확장 실험들은
동일한 원자 빔을 여러 슈테른-게를라흐 장치에 통과시켜서 다양한 상황에서 스핀이 어떻게 행동하는지 알아봐요.
여기 하나를 소개할게요. 원자 빔을 한 장치에 통과시켜서 스핀 업 빔과 스핀 다운 빔 두 개로 나누고
그 두 빔 각각을 별도의
장치에 통과시켜 볼게요. Qiskit에서 이 실험에 해당하는 quantum circuit은 마지막 것과 비슷하지만
측정이 두 번이에요. 여기서는 오븐의 효과를 모방했던 무작위 회전을
Hadamard라는 gate로 교체했어요. Hadamard를 적용하면 오븐과 동일한 측정 확률이 나오거든요.
하지만 사용하기가 훨씬 간단해요. 그래서 한 번 측정하고 두 번 측정하는데
실험 결과 측정 히스토그램은 이렇게 생겼어요. X축의 비트 문자열은 두 번 측정의
결과에 해당해요. qubit이 두 번 모두 0으로 측정되면 00 비트 문자열에 해당하고, 또는
처음 0 그다음 1로 측정되면 10에 해당하는 식이에요. 첫 번째 실험에서 스핀 업으로 측정되면 두 번째에서도 스핀 업이 될 것 같아요.
스핀 다운 원자도 마찬가지예요. 즉 첫 번째 실험에서는 업이나 다운을 측정할 확률이 같지만, 두 번째 실험에서는 결과가 이미 결정된 거예요.
그래서 두 번째 슈테른-게를라흐 장치 각각의 끝에 있는 두 스크린에는 각각 하나의 점만 있을 거예요.
한 스크린에는 스핀 업 원자가 모두 있고 다른 스크린에는 스핀 다운 원자가 모두 있을 거예요. 다음 실험으로
순수하게 스핀 업 원자 빔으로 시작해 볼게요. 실제 물리적 슈테른-게를라흐 실험에서는 슈테른-게를라흐 장치에 통과시키고
아래로 편향된 빔을 차단함으로써 이걸 할 수 있어요. 그러면 위로 편향된 원자들이 모두
스핀 업이 돼요. 이제 이 빔을 또 다른 슈테른-게를라흐 장치에 통과시키되, 이번에는 자석을 90° 회전시켜서
자기장 기울기가 이쪽으로 이동하는 원자들을 위아래 대신 좌우로 편향시키도록 해요. 하나의 점이 보일까요 두 개의 점이 보일까요 아니면 완전히 다른 게 보일까요? 이 실험을 위해
Qiskit에서 다음 circuit을 실행할 거예요. 이 실험의 원자 빔이 모두 스핀 업이므로 0 상태에서 시작해요.
그런 다음 이 Hadamard gate가 x와 z 좌표를 교환해서
슈테른-게를라흐 장치를 회전시키는 효과를 내요. 이제 위아래 대신 좌우 스핀 투영을 측정하는 거예요.
여기서 이런 모양의 측정 히스토그램을 얻어요. X 방향의 스핀도
두 가지 값만 취할 수 있다는 걸 알 수 있어요. 스핀 레프트와 스핀 라이트라고 부를 수 있어요.
그래서 이 실험은 이전에 Z 방향으로 스핀 업으로 측정된 스핀의 X 투영을 측정하면 같은 확률로 스핀 레프트 또는 라이트가 나온다는 걸 보여줘요.
마지막으로 고전적 기대와 대조해서 차이를 정말 명확하게 부각시켜 볼게요.
고전적으로는 작은 원자 막대자석이 장치의 자기장 기울기에 수직으로 가리키면
그 원자에 작용하는 힘이 0이어야 한다고 했던 거 기억하죠. 위아래로 편향되지 않아야 해요. 그 경우 스크린 한가운데에 하나의 점만 보여야 해요.
그런데 두 개의 점이 보여요. 즉 절반의 원자는 스핀 레프트이고 절반은 스핀 라이트예요.
이전에 업으로 측정됐는데도요. 그래서 양자역학적 관점에서 보면, 스핀 업을 위를 가리키는 벡터에,
스핀 다운을 아래를 가리키는 벡터에 대응시키고 싶을 수 있지만, 마지막 실험에서 볼 수 있듯이 그렇게 단순하지 않아요.
여기서 무슨 일이 일어나는지 정말 이해하려면 양자 중첩과 측정이라는 주제를 더 깊이 파고들어야 해요.
이건 다른 날 영상에서 다룰 거예요. 양자역학이 정확히 어떻게 작동하는지에 대한 더 많은 의문이 남은 것처럼
슈테른과 게를라흐도 그랬어요. 그들의 실험이 모든 걸 설명하지는 못했지만
자연 세계를 이해하는 데 양자역학이 필수적이라는 걸 확립하는 데 크게 기여했어요.
그 실험은 양자역학에서 가장 중요한 기초 실험 중 하나였어요. 운동량의 양자화를 증명하고
스핀이라는 자연의 새로운 기본 특성에 대한 증거를 제공했어요. 양자 세계의 법칙을 정말로 이해하고
세계였어요. 그 실험은 양자역학에서 가장 중요한 기초 실험 중 하나로, 운동량의 양자화를 증명하고
스핀이라는 자연의 새로운 기본 특성에 대한 증거를 제공했어요. 양자 세계의 규칙을 정말로 이해하고 씨름하기 위해
슈테른과 게를라흐 같은 물리학자들은 직접 손을 더럽혀야 했어요. 실험을 직접 설계하면서요.
실험하고 예측을 세우고 때로는 틀리기도 하면서요. 직접 해보는 것을 대체할 건 진짜 없어요.
그러니 실제 양자 실험을 직접 해보고 싶다면 슈테른-게를라흐 모듈로 가보세요.
설명란에 링크가 있어요. 시청해 주셔서 감사하고 다음에 또 봬요.